revenir à l'entraînement et faire ses
premières foulées c'est toujours ce
moment si particulier où il faut passer
à autre chose
un mois et demi après une compétition
extraordinaire comme les jeux
paralympiques
une coupure pendant laquelle nantenin
keita licencié à le à saint quentin a dû
gérer la décompression post olympique
mais la déception de ne pas être revenu
avec le plus beau métal de londres est
encore présente dans un coin de la tête
je sais quand même la compétition un
signe suprême c'est c'est tous les
quatre ans et aujourd'hui je suis à un
âge avancé et je sais pas si j'aurai la
chance de refaire d'autres
donc oui oui il ya quand même le goût
amer parce que parce que parce que ça
finit par chenilles pas sur l'olympiade
ou par les amap cède que je voulais en
fait et je pense que nous sommes aux
hammers bourré je n'aurais pendant
longtemps son objectif même si elle ne
dit pas c'est un jour de décrocher une
médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
donc c'est ça c'est un vrai objectif
donc il ya un goût amer parce que
parce qu'elle n'a pas eu à pékin elle
n'a pas la sphère argent et bronze là
elle fait une bronze c'est toujours
parce qu'elle voudrait la principale
préoccupation est tout autre pour
l'instant éviter les blessures ces
douleurs qui ont mis les l'athlète
saint-quentinoise ces deux dernières
saisons je pense que mon corps est
fatigué et qu'en fait mon corps je n'ai
jamais ménagé donc donc au bout d'un
moment il dit stop
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai fait pas
mal de saisons je m'entraînais dur et où
il avait pas de suivi médical derrière
et j'ai une façon de courir en fait qui
est assez brutal pour mon corps donc
vous coup bah ouais bout d'un moment et
crac d'antonin court désormais vers son
prochain objectif les championnats du
monde à lyon en juillet 2013 avant de se
laisser peut-être tentés par de nouveaux
défis comme le 400 m e et pendant que
l'ombre s'efface foulée après foulée la
médaille à les ranger au chaud
maintenant elle a fait un petit parcours
là parce que j'ai fait pas mal de
l'intervention la semaine dernière donc
à chaque fois donnant de ramener la
médaille mais mais ça et c'est bon là à
les ranger chapitres suivants chapitre
est souvent